u
O On poursuit avec les ministre
dede la Santé. M. Dubé, bonsoir.
- - Bonsoir.
- - M. Dubé, vous avez dit :
"C"Ce qu'est-ce qui se passe
nonous préoccupe." Qu'est-ce qui
vovous préoccupe?
CHCHRISTIAN DUBÉ, ministre Santé
etet Services sociaux, Québec
- - C'est sûr que la montée des
cacas nous préoccupe. Par contr,
onon n'a pas vu encore d'impact
mamajeur sur les hospitalisatio,
alalors c'est ça qu'il faut...
onon a dit depuis plusieurs
sesemaines que c'est ce qu'on dt
susurveiller.
- - Bon, on a je vais vous
momontrer un tableau justement :
1414 décembre 2021 et 14 décembe
202020. Il y avait 890
hohospitalisations; il y en a 2.
LeLe 890, c'est le maximum qu'on
nene peut plus jamais dépasser.
EsEst-ce que c'est ça ou c'est
mmême plus bas que ça??
- - Bien, il faut regarder... le
nonombre de lits, c'est une cho,
mamais d'avoir le personnel pour
popouvoir... servir nos patient.
EnEn ce moment, notre maximum...
lilits COVID, sans faire du
dédélestage additionnel dans nos
chchirurgies ou nos urgences,
c'c'est ça, un petit peu plus de
80800. Alors, c'est pour ça qu'l
fafaut pas se rapprocher trop de
cece chiffre et avoir d'autres
imimpacts sur le réseau.
- - Mais vos experts vous disent
ququ'avec l'entrée d'un écran, n
popourrait atteindre ce seuil
d'd'hospitalisation à quel mome?
- - Beaucoup plus en janvier et
féfévrier, dépendamment de...
paparce qu'on a appris que le
vavariant Omicron est beaucoup
plplus contagieux, donc il va
rerechercher les gens plplus
rarapidement, mais on n'est pas
enencore certain de sa sévérité.
AlAlors, ça ne veut pas dire que
leles gens iraient plus à
l'l'hôpital. Alors, il y a encoe
bebeaucoup d'hypothèses à vérifr
dadans les prochaines semaines,
mamais pour être certain, c'est
popour ça qu'on n'a dit
auaujourd'hui qu'il fallait en
plplus accélérer la troisième de
paparce qu'il y a une chose est
cecertain, c'est que la troisièe
dodose, la dose rappelle, va
pepermettre aussi d'être plus
efefficace pour vaincre Omicron
ququand il sera avec nous.
- - Justement, pour la troisième
dodose, le Québec est un peu en
reretard par rapport à l'Ontari,
papar exemple, où eux, c'est la
popopulation générale. Nous, c't
7070 ans et plus ou les traverse
lala santé, et c'est en janvier,
leles 60 ans et plus. Il n'y a s
momoyen d'accélérer ça?
- - En fait, oui, mais ça nous
prprend plus de vaccinateurs. En
grgros, on vaccine à peu près, n
cece moment, 300 000 personnes r
sesemaine. Si on se remet à l'éé
dedernier, lorsqu'on vaccinait u
mamaximum, on vaccine est à peu
prprès 800 000 personnes par
sesemaine. Alors, c'est pour vos
didire qu'en ce moment, on
vovoudrait vacciner plus, mais n
esest limitée par le nombre de
vavaccinateurs.
- - Avez-vous, là-dessus, envoyé
trtrop vite déjà à la maison?
- - Les gens voulaient arrêter.
DeDes gens, il y en a qui sont s
SnSnowbirds qui sont retournés n
FlFloride. Ce sont des gens qui
didisaient : "Moi, ça fait un an
quque je fais ça. J'ai fait ma
papart. Les cas ont baissé." Ona
reretourné du personnel qui état
dadans les vaccinations, on lesa
reretournés dans les hôpitaux, n
leles a retournés dans nos groue
dede médecine familiale pour que
lala machine continue à prendre
dedes rendez-vous, etc.
- - Alors, comment on va faire
popour la troisième dose s'il ny
a a pas 500 nouvelles personness
ququi cognent à la porte?
- - Moi, je suis certain qu'il a
y y en avoir, parce que les gens
sosont pas tous partis en Florie
jujustemenent, puis ils y en a i
vovont peut-être avoir pris 2-3
sesemaines, un mois de repos, ps
ququi ont été jusqu'à maintenant
exexcessivement collaborateurs.
OnOn dit qu'à chaque 100
vavaccinateurs, on va chercher
10100 000 personnes par semaine,
fafait que c'est beaucoup. Alor,
chchaque fois qu'on va aller
chchercher 100 000 personnes de
plplus, au lieu de 300 000, si n
esest à 400 000, je fais mes
trtravailleurs de la santé plus
rarapidement, je fais mes
pepersonnes vulnérables plus
rarapidement. Et plus on va allr
chchercher la troisième dose, ps
onon va se protéger contre un
OmOmicron qui serait probablemet
trtrès présent en janvier.
- - Ce qui est frappant, M. Dub,
c'c'est comment, à chaque
opopération, on est au bout de a
cocorde, dans tout : il manque s
ininfirmières, il manque de tou.
LeLe délestage, c'est pas fini.
VoVous dites : "Là, on va aller
ararracher 500 personnes." Commt
çaça se fait que notre système t
sisi étiré?
- - Parce qu'on l'étire depuis
lolongtemps. Je veux pas faire e
popolitique aujourd'hui, c'est s
lele temps, mais ça fait 20 ans
quque c'est comme ça. Et pour m,
d'd'où je viens, dans les
enentreprises ou les organisatis
quque j'ai gérées, il faut
totoujours avoir 10 à 15 % du
pepersonnel qu'on a besoin pour
papallier aux imprévus. Là, on a
2020 % de moins de personnel qul
fafaut. On n'en a pas 15 % de
plplus, on en a 20 % de moins,
fafait qu'on est toujours au
bobouchon, comme on appelle. Qud
onon va... et c'est pour ça qu'n
veveut ce changement de culture,
onon veut ramener des gens pour
didire : l'environnement de
trtravail va être meilleur. Plus
ilil y a des gens qui vont
revevenir...
- - Les infirmières, M. Dubé,
papardonnez-moi, mais ça n'a pas
mamarché beaucoup. Votre appel..
vovous vous êtes presque mis à
gegenoux, vous avez dit : "On va
memettre de l'argent." Il n'y ea
papas beaucoup...
- - S'il faut que je me mette à
gegenoux, je vais me mettre à
gegenoux. Mais je vais vous dire
dedeux choses : premièrement, ot
enen a déjà ramené 2500. Je le
didis, là, sur le 4000 qu'on
chcherchait, il y en a 2500 qui
sosont déjà là. Mais ça en prend
plplus. Alors, il y a aussi des
chchoses qu'on va améliorer. Aps
dedes discussions, justement, sr
lele terrain, parler au syndica,
ilil y avait des éléments dans
nonotre programme de rappel qu'n
dedevait améliorer, par exemple
dedes congés sans solde, des
chchoses comme ça. On a tout
cocorriger ça, et là, on le remt
dedevant les employés et on leur
dodonne un mois de plus, c'est--
didire qu'on leur donne jusqu'àa
mimi-janvier, parce que là, je
pepense que les aménagements
coconvient de faire sont très
imimportants, ils vont aider les
gegens à revenir avec nous.
- - Vous avez annoncé... d'abor,
vovous avez dit que c'est pas
teterminé, en voulant dire qu'on
esespérait que ce soit terminé,l
y y a beaucoup de gens qui nous
écécoutent...
- - On veut tous.
- - On espérait que ce soit
teterminé un peu et c'est pas
teterminé. Et donc, vous allez
jujusqu'à dire : "Le télétravai,
leles entreprises du Québec,
raramener votre monde en
tétélétravail." Il y a pas quele
chchose de décourageant totalemt
llà-dedans?
- - Écoutez, je dis souvent qu'l
fafaut rester en avant de la
paparade. C'est ce que c'est pas
dedes décisions faciles, mais
sasavait que c'était la plus
évévidente. Savez-vous, à chaque
fofois qu'on a un nouveau varia,
cece qu'on veut, c'est limité le
nonombre de contacts. Le variant
sese... raffole des contacts ene
leles personnes, alors il faut
évéviter les contacts. Il y a un
enendroit, milieu de travail,
auaussi facile d'éviter les
cocontacts, on la montrait. On
aiaime ça être en présentiel. Vs
etet moi, c'est la première
fofois... première fois, mais ça
fafait combien de fois qu'on fat
dedes entrevues, vous et moi,
papar... Teams ou peu importe?
AlAlors donc, c'est ça qu'il fat
didire : pendant un certain tem,
lilimitons les contacts pour
évéviter les cas.
- - Vous me voyez venir : limits
leles contacts. La semaine
dedernière, j'avais le Dr Arruda
enen entrevue. Il me dit : "20
pepersonnes." D'abord, on a
l'l'impression qu'il aurait pu
didire 25, 15, 10. Là, allez-vos
rereculer là-dessus où vous allz
didire : dans le fond, soyez le
plplus responsable possible, mas
onon ne peut plus toucher à ça.
- - C'est ce qu'on a dit la
sesemaine passée. Soyons clairs,
onon a dit... Dr Arruda a dit :
"J"Jusqu'à 20 personnes." On n't
papas obligé d'aller sur le
mamaximum, mais en ce moment, il
fafallait aussi avant l'adhésion
dedes gens. On le sait, vous, vs
êêtes tanné, moi aussi, je suis
tatanné et tout le monde est
tatanné. On se fie à... au bon
jujugement des Québécois, qui ot
étété très discipliné jusqu'à
mamaintenant.
- - Vous allez pas revenir à
d'd'autres consignes??
- - Écoutez, c'est sûr que si on
avavait 4000 hospitalisations
dedemain et que...
- - Ça arrivera pas.
- - Ça arrivera pas, mais ce que
jeje veux dire, c'est qu'en ce
momoment, on ne voit pas de rain
dede le faire. Mais je vais vous
didire aussi que des fois, on
s's'est réajusté très rapidement
sisi la situation changeait. En
OnOntario, là, ils sont passés -
dedessus de 20 % du Omicron, de
cacas Omicron, pardon. Il n'y en
avavait pas il y a 2-3 semaines.
AlAlors, il faut juste être
prprudent dans l'ajustement qu'n
dodoit faire.
- - Je vais vous reposer la
ququestion différemment, M. Dub:
sisi vous aviez eu à prendre la
dédécision aujourd'hui pour Noë,
sasachant ce que vous savez sur
l'l'Omicron, auriez-vous donné e
fefeu vert à 20 personnes?
- - Oui, la réponse est oui.
- - Quand même?
- - Quand même, parce qu'il état
imimportant de garder l'adhésion
dedes gens pour...
paparticulièrement ceux qui ont
dédécidé de se faire vaccicinere
didire : des fois, on a besoin e
pepetits cadeaux, on a besoin de
sese faire plaisir. 20 personnes
vavaccinées qui se voient à Noë,
c'c'est correct, voilà.
- - Parce que même si vous aviez
ininterdit, on peut se demanderi
leles Québécois auraient suivi.
- - Bien, c'est ça, puis les ges
ququi sont vaccinés et qui se
vovoient entre eux... regardez,n
esest ensemble, mais il faut le
fafaire dans un environnement
cocorrect, et je pense qu'on se
fifiant jusqu'à maintenant au
jujugement des Québécois, on a
asassez bien réussi.
- - Un petit mot, avant de vous
lalaisser aller, sur les tests
rarapides. Pour ceux qui ont des
sysymptômes, pour les enfants, s
popour : ah! Je vais m'amuser, u
cacas... c'est pas un alcootest,
llà.
- - Non, mais c'est ça...
LaLa bonne nouvelle, c'est que ,
onon en a beaucoup parce que onn
a a donné... on en a déjà donné
auaux parents et ceux qui ont ds
enenfants, aux écoles. On en a s
dadans les sacs des enfants. Pus
enen plus, le fédéral s'est engé
àà nous en envoyer un autre 3
mimillions dans les prochains
jojours pour ici le 20 décembre.
AlAlors tout ça mis ensemble...n
vava expliquer, il y a des bells
vividéos qui expliquent comment
fafaire l'auto-test, car on s'en
vava là, vers l'autodépistage.
- - Gratuit partout.
- - Gratuit, c'est pas juste das
leles pharmacies.
- - Mais ne pas le faire
ininutilement, vous dites.
- - Voilà, quand on est
sysymptomatique, c'est-à-dire
ququ'on a un nez qui coule, on a
dedes symptômes, on le fait, pus
apaprès ça, on peut aller vévérr
dadans un centre de dépistage.
- - On a vu le petit vidéo et ls
gegens vont pouvoir regarder ça.
C'C'est pas très compliqué.
- - Non, c'est simple.
- - M. Dubé, je sais pas si on e
rereparlera, mais sinon je vous
sosouhaite de joyeuses fêtes qud
mmême, malgré tout ça.
- - Il le faut, on va passer à
trtravers puis on va avoir un bu
tetemps des Fêtes quand même.
- - Merci, M. Dubé.
AÀ la prochaine.
- - Merci beaucoup